by order of the overseer counsel this
pile is subject to level four
classification level four clearance is
required security clearance adequate
access in file good afternoon today
we're going to be looking at SC p 8j
class Euclid special containment
procedures a CP 8 samples have been
deemed class 5 extreme biological
hazards and all related protocols apply
incineration and irradiation measures
will be deployed in the event of a
political or military action which may
result in the facility being dismantled
a power failure or zero communications
from operatives or outside channels
during any given 8 hour period the
quarantine period for operatives leaving
the facility is 4 months if a breach has
occurred incineration and irradiation
measures shall be deployed it should be
the policy of all g2 sites to not
prepare an evacuation procedure
description SCP 8 is a complex pryin
samples of which are stored in each of
the known g2 sites
research into SCP 8 is highly classified
and primarily aimed at preventing
research which may lead to the synthesis
of SCP a in the distant future traits of
the SCP 8 pryin include 100%
infectiousness 100% lethality
transmission through exposed mucous
membranes and all bodily fluids not
airborne or waterborne symptoms of
infection with SCP eight men efest no
more than three hours after exposure and
include flu-like symptoms with high
fever plus severe dementia in later
stages coma onset approximately 20 hours
after the first symptoms appear and 12
hours after noticeable dementia coma
onset will be considered onset of death
a period of sporadic cellular necrosis
occurs which comes to resemble gangrene
surviving tissue assumes its original
function and is highly resilient red
blood cells greatly increase oxygen
storage capacity resulting in slower
blood flow and increased muscle
endurance and strength nervous and
muscular systems are unaffected by total
organ failure for several hours
metabolism may decrease to extremely low
levels allowing subject to survive for
over 10 years
without nutrition high blood viscosity
results in negligible blood flow from
gunshot and slashing injuries condition
behavior motor controls and instinctive
behavioral mechanisms are damaged and
cognitive abilities are severely
[ __ ] and erratic animals experience
excessive brain necrosis and are
inactive subject can adapt to its
damaged nervous systems but is limited
to basic physical activities including
standing up balancing on two legs
walking biting grabbing and crawling
subject will energetically move towards
sights sounds and smells it associates
with living humans subject will attempt
to ingest living humans if physical
contact is made neutralizing fully
infected subjects requires significant
cranial trauma there is strong evidence
to suggest that SCP 8 it self did not
form naturally on earth since variants
of similar complexity would have
displaced much of the ecosystem in 1959
a short collaborative effort with the
USSR to locate g2 sites and eliminate
SCP eight was negotiated following their
discovery the status of scp-821 scp-500
has been found to be able to completely
cure a cp8 even in the advanced stages
of the disease
if you had adequate clearance to listen
to this file this has been SC p 8n d'ang
transmission